[Applause]
has it to combo
and some separation and frustration and
this was all because of the previous
play
with the nasus and Blake Griffin right
so a timeout 125 to go
Celtics in control in the final seconds
here in Milwaukee
well fireworks here towards the end of
this game here here's the foul looks
like the NASA's got away with a hook
there on Blake wasn't called
here's the somewhat hard foul Bible
commits the first place penalty one for
Unnecessary contact above the shoulders
followed by a flagrant Falcon 22 head
butt by onakupa he's been ejected from
the game coach from Boston will pick
from the office bench and she can play
with foul free throws and he's ripping
and she's two free throws for the play
foul penalty two in Boston 24 on the
shot
okay well explain there the nasus has
been flagrant two kicked out of the ball
game Joe mozulla
will be able to pick a player from the
Milwaukee bench